what are the most popular things folks
design on canva ah the range of things
people design on canva is pretty
astronomical presentations are really
popular we've had 1 billion
presentations created uh recently
everything from social media Graphics to
marketing materials videos print
products a whole Suite of products that
um people have now created 15 billion
designs with 200 new designs every
second is that right I think that's
correct yeah pretty
crazy
[Music]
hi Melanie thank you so much for doing
this ah it's so good to be here with you
how's the weather in Sydney it's been
really lovely we've had some really
lovely sunny weather for our winter why
did you start Cana um many years ago I
was at University and I was teaching
design program programs and I thought
they were extraordinarily complicated it
would take a whole semester for people
to learn the very Basics and so I
believed in the future everything would
be online and collaborative and really
simple and we've been really working
towards that now for the last decade by
Wii you mean you and your co-founders
and one of your co-founders I believe
became your future husband right yeah
well he was actually my boyfriend before
he became my co-founder Cliff it it's
quite funny looking back like you know
obviously over the last decade I've had
to learn about venture capital and Angel
invest and just like the whole
vocabulary and the whole world but at
that point in time we were just like
well let's create some
[Music]
software flashforward 10 years and
canvas been valued as high as $40
billion making it one of the world's
most valuable private software companies
But continuing to grow and compete with
companies like Adobe and Microsoft will
be no small task and unlike other Tech
Giants this software company is a ways
away from Silicon Valley
the company's based in Sydney is that an
advantage or a disadvantage I think it's
a massive Advantage so vast majority of
our product work is done in
Australia we have been in a very
fortunate position that we've been
profitable for the last 6 years um we've
got 3,900 people in our team we've been
continuing to grow our team so we' we've
become very Global so we're in 85% of
Fortune 500s um from the HR department
to the people team to um marketing and
sales as I understand you have a
dedicated head of Vibes we do and you've
got like a 70 person team focused on
just creating a Vibe tell me about
this I guess when we started out we
always wanted to create a company that
we wanted to work at in the early days
Cliff would make lunch for everyone and
we've just kind of kept that rolling and
so now we've got almost 4,000 people and
obviously Cliff can't make lunch for
everyone so um you know we've got 70
amazing people in our Vibe team who you
know they help create celebrations and
they help create team bonding events and
they help create the office environment
and Vibe uh to keep everyone together
and feeling great do you think of canva
as an antidote to the sort of
stereotypical Tech bro culture of
Silicon
Valley I don't know I I've just always
focused on doing it our way doing it the
way that makes sense for us if that's an
antidote I mean so be it let's talk
about AI what is canvas's AI strategy
the whole premise of canva was to make
design simpler and easier for everyone
like that was the Genesis and we're in a
really fortunate position that AI just
really accelerates that and so we have
been deeply um embedding AI across the
entirety of our visual Suite so inside
our products you can now use generative
AI to create
content you can edit a photo and add
something in do you want me to show you
yeah let's do it okay I'll share you
this link so we can collaborate together
and then I'll show you some magic
features it pops up all these different
templates that you can choose from
should we do a presentation on AI and
software Ai and
software wow that was fast and then you
can come here and you can replace
anything that you like let's get a
picture of San Francisco and you can
just drag and drop and place it into
your on your page so let's go there we
go beautiful what would you like in the
water Dolphins oh Dolphins yeah let's do
that okay wow that's crazy
cool when canva first came onto the
scene it had an immediate Edge over
software Giants by appealing to more
casual users but now Adobe longtime a
top seller of creative software has had
time to catch up with competing
userfriendly tools plans to buy figma a
global web design platform and its
investments in generative AI what makes
you think you can beat them I think
there was a huge gap in the market and
so it's not necessarily competing but
creating something that filled a gap
that people really experienced you sort
of have Microsoft on one side which was
very um you know not necessarily very
beautiful and then you have Adobe on the
other side that was very complicated and
we saw this Gap in the Middle where
people wanted to design something really
great to express their Concepts and to
achieve their goals but they didn't
necessarily have years to invest in
learning the tools and then with canva
obviously we've just done use this same
platform so you can design each of these
different things with the same ease so
you can design a presentation as easily
as you can design a
website I think something that we're
really excited about is combining all of
these different aspects together and we
think that we're in a great position to
help do this dance where we take
technology and we take creativity and we
combine them together because AI does a
great job at some things but not other
things like creating a really authentic
image is something that AI does not do a
great job of so combining them together
to help people achieve their goals is
very much where we focused and we're
extraordinarily excited to create the
magic over the next decade well here's
to try to make more magic we'll be
watching thank you so much Emily lovely
to chat with
[Music]
you thank you so
much
[Music]